the FBI destroyed former national
security adviser Michael Flynn's life
for political purposes according to new
documents that have been released years
after the fact and for some reason the
mainstream media that colluded with the
bureaucrats to trash the general don't
want to run the story Yahoo News spreads
lies straight to the president's face
which is unwise when you're dealing with
Donald Trump and even that story about
the poor confused lady who was convinced
by Trump to feed her husband fish tank
cleaner to stop the coronavirus turns
out to be shady all of which brings up
an important political reality all news
is fake some of its true but all of its
fake then power-mad politicians get
crueler and crueler with no end in sight
and finally the mailbag all that and
more I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
all news is fake even if some of it is
true all of it is fake how is that
possible we'll get to it in a second but
first I want to know which of the news
outlets is the fakest which I know it's
a tough competition there are a lot of
options here but which if you had to
rate one CNN New York Times MSNBC which
one would you say is the fakest also
before we get into the craziest fake
news story of the last year at least of
the last year there's so many of them
I've got to thank our friends over at
Rock Auto if your car is having trouble
Rock Auto is a godsend right now isn't
it because a lot of places are not
exactly open and even if they were
rockauto.com is catalogued is unique
it's remarkably easy to navigate it's so
much better than going to
brick-and-mortar quickly see all the
parts available for your vehicle and
choose the brands specifications and
prices you prefer rockauto.com is a
family business serving Auto Parts
customers online for 20 years
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
price as possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear so it goes up
and down and they're all these gimmicks
no way so if you happen to need a Dell
5fg 1456 fuel pump assembly for 2005
2010 Honda Odyssey let's say costs three
hundred fifty four dollars at a big
chain store well at Rock Auto you can
get it for two hundred and seventeen
bucks that's just one example head on
over to rockauto.com right now see all
the parts available for your car or
truck right Knowles in there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you the biggest fake news story of
at least the last year it's while there
was impeachment so I guess maybe it's
tied with impeachment but certainly the
biggest fake news story not directly
involving Donald Trump and we just found
out about it yesterday Michael Flynn do
you remember Michael Flynn he's been out
of the news after they after they
scalped him through the mainstream media
Michael Flynn was the incoming national
security adviser when Donald Trump got
elected then we heard that the FBI found
out he did something with the Russians
and foreign
governments and we don't know exactly
and it's all very vague but anyway he's
out of his job and he's going to jail if
he doesn't cut a deal with the
government turns out it now appears that
the FBI set him up and they didn't just
set him up to nab him for some
wrongdoing he did they set him up for
political purposes this is according to
handwritten notes which were just
released so the FBI investigation they
they had these various goals into Flynn
Flynn was coming in as the NSA and he
had spoken to some foreign officials
including some from Russia this is back
don't forget when they were pushing the
idea that the Trump administration was
colluding with the Russians they used
the Russians to rig the election
obviously we found that that was based
on absolutely nothing and ironically we
found out the only group that did
collude with the Russians was the
Hillary Clinton campaign in the
Democratic Party which paid a foreign
operative with ties to Moscow to set up
Trump with that fake steel dossier all
of that st. in history and it's going to
come back but we'll get to that another
day specifically here we're talking
about Mike Flynn because Mike Flynn he's
a private citizen but he's about to
become the National Security Advisor she
was talking to people from foreign
governments and the FBI decides they're
gonna get him on this for a violation of
a 1799 law called the Logan Act which no
one has ever been successfully
prosecuted for but it borrows private
citizens from negotiating with foreign
governments so that was one goal that
they had in dealing with Flynn and that
was absolutely ridiculous I don't think
anybody ever takes that seriously then
the alternate goal was to get Flynn to
admit to some wrongdoing and talking to
this foreign government or to catch him
in a lie so far so good okay because
even though it's pretty shady law
enforcement does this all the time
either they get you to admit to doing
something wrong or they set you up so
that you lie and then they've got you
and they can prosecute you that's not
even the biggest problem the biggest
problem here is the last little part in
the hand
written notes they say a key goal of the
agents investigating Flynn was quote to
get him to lie so we can prosecute him
or get him fired this is the big problem
actually a lot of the reporting on this
right now which is only being done in
conservative outlets it's focusing on
the idea that they're going to try to
catch them in a lie but law enforcement
does that all the time is it ugly is it
ugly when it's an incoming
administration that law enforcement is
targeting yes of course is it is it even
shocking to our Democratic sensibilities
yes but it's this or get him fired the
FBI did not want Michael Flynn to be the
National Security Advisor they had
political problems with him if it were
that he committed a crime and they want
to get him then okay prosecute him for
it but get him fired is just more
evidence of what we've seen from the
very beginning which is that the FBI bad
actors in the DOJ and the FBI were
interfering in the political process in
this country because they didn't want
Donald Trump to get elected president
because they didn't like his politics
they didn't like him personally we saw
this in the emails or the text messages
rather from FBI agents Peter struck and
Lisa page those adulterous deep state
agents we saw this from the very
beginning right you saw text messages
from people at the FBI and DOJ saying we
won't let Donald Trump become president
don't worry we've got an insurance
policy and so this is no it's no
surprise I guess it's just a surprise
that we now see the documents and now it
looks like Michael Flynn will either
have this case dismissed or he will be
pardoned by the president which he
should it is outrageous from flynn's
lawyer the government produced to mr.
Flynn's stunning Brady evidence that
proves mr. Flynn's allegations of having
been deliberately set up and framed by
corrupt agents at the top of the FBI the
government has deliberately suppressed
this evidence from the inception of this
prosecution knowing there was no crime
by mr. Flynn probably the first
place you're hearing about this is
either on this show or maybe on a
conservative website you certainly have
not heard about this first from the
mainstream media because they're not
covering it they covered the baseless
allegations they covered the absolute
corrupt set up you know the the FBI line
the DOJ line they covered that ad
nauseam for years but the exoneration
they don't cover because all news is
fake even the news that is true is fake
president Trump Illustrated this point
just the other day he was giving a press
conference he was sitting with governor
Ron de Santos of Florida and a reporter
was insistent that the numbers the data
were so much worse than Trump was
suggesting it was then it turned out
guess what Yahoo News got the data wrong
has done five times more tests than the
US per capita the White House said the
u.s. passes South Colonie fibers testing
who are you with hai-yah who news well
be looking at this just want to make it
clear that um South Korea's testing was
11 per per a hundred thousand and we're
at 17 well no but based on the numbers
that I had which are obviously
completely fictional and just came out
of my imagination it turns out you've
done terrible job mr. president
yeah but what about the actual numbers
from the data no no but look I didn't do
anything wrong even though I completely
lied I my numbers could not have
possibly been more wrong but I said them
and I'm wearing a suit and tie and I'm
the very serious mainstream media so I'm
not going to apologize I love the way
Trump handles it here says yeah you
gonna you know doctor because what does
he know right Trump it's not like Trump
has all of the data right in front of
him at any given moment so he says I
don't think those numbers are right
buster but I don't know okay I guess
we'll go check them doctor Bert
says no I've got them right here the
numbers are not right because oh yeah
your fake news this is why no one
listens to you that's why no one pays
attention to you because you're the
lying fake news why did I even think
otherwise and dr. Burke is trying to be
like the nice mom
kind of there she's like okay well just
maybe you know next time check the
numbers Trump is like yeah you're a liar
and no one should ever pay attention to
you again and that's true of the entire
mainstream media apparatus I'll give you
an example even of a kind of a silly
story I mean it's not silly because it's
sort of sad and it's sort of mysterious
and it's getting darker by the moment
but you know it's not a story of
national security or national importance
you remember when President Trump was
talking about that drug
hydroxychloroquine which was showing a
lot of promise to treat the corona virus
and then there's this story where a
woman and her husband drank the fishtank
cleaner because one of the ingredients
was chloroquine phosphate and was just
not obviously it's not the drug that was
being used to trigger rotavirus but it
had the word chloroquine in it so they
drink fish tank cleaner and the husband
dies and all of us at the time we said
ah something here doesn't sound right
but they portrayed it as Oh Trump told
us to take this drug and my my husband
died and I'm so distraught about it well
even that story which was being pushed
in the mainstream media as like Trump is
responsible for this guy's death turns
out it's now being investigated as a
murder
and the murderer in this case is not
suspected to be President Trump it's the
wife like a lot of us suggested in the
first place we'll get to the details of
that in just one second because it's a
pretty pretty dark and mysterious story
but first I got to thank our friends
over at banda you know right now during
some economic tough times companies need
to make sure that their HR house is in
order seriously especially with the regs
changing by the hour it seems when
running a business HR issues can kill
you wrongful termination suits minimum
width rate wage requirements labor
regulations and HR manager salaries are
not cheap you know the average HR
manager in America
make 70 grand a year Bambi spelled BA
MBE e was created specifically for your
small business you get a dedicated HR
manager in craft HR policy and maintain
your compliance all for just $99 a month
I know that seems unbelievable too good
Bambi does it they're amazing with Bambi
you can change HR from your biggest
liability to your biggest strength your
dedicated HR managers available by phone
email or real-time chat absolutely
important service right now
Bambi comm slash Michael go there right
now to schedule your free HR audit
that's Bambi comm slash Michael BAM to
the B EE com
slash Michael okay you cannot afford the
risk of not having your HR in order so
the story about the fish tank cleaner Oh
a lot of us looked at it we said I don't
I don't think president Trump's
responsible for this guy's death I'm a
little skeptical that this death was an
accident to begin with so now a homicide
unit is investigating the death of this
man this is the Mesa City Police
Department's Homicide Division
investigating the death of Gary Linnaeus
who is the the Arizona man whose wife
gave him a coca-cola or some kind of
soft drink mixed with the fish tank
cleaner that she said she did to save
him from the coronavirus a detective
handling the case confirmed the
Washington free beacon that all of this
is happening after speaking with
Linnaeus his wife Wanda you know there
was a story that came out after the
death which said that the Arizona man
who died from drinking fish tank cleaner
was known as a very intelligent man and
a lot of people on the internet they
said I wasn't that intelligent if he's
drinking fish tank cleaner but actually
the point of that headline the point of
that story was something doesn't sit
right I think he was a mechanical
engineer and his pretty sharp guy
apparently there was a troubled marriage
the wife was apparently vicious to him
in public according to multiple reports
so now this story which was originally
posed as Trump's loose mouth is causing
people to die all around the country
because his irresponsible words he's got
blood on his hands now the story is a
woman
possibly murdered her husband and then
blamed Trump for it just like the
mainstream media blame Trump for every
single thing do you think the mainstream
media are gonna cover that part of the
story no it's just drive-by it's just
you take the snipe at Trump who cares if
it's true or not you take the snipe you
take out his national security adviser
based on nothing
based on crook FBI agents okay that's
fine we'll move on oh he's gonna get
exonerated later my own no big deal
we're already gonna be so far past that
story that it's not going to matter at
all don't forget the Fiesta Resistance
the Joe Biden story the Joe Biden oh my
gosh the Cavanaugh allegations went on
minute by minute 24/7 at 24 hours a day
seven days a week for that whole hearing
and even afterward Christine Blasi Ford
believe all women Brett Kavanaugh who's
just some milquetoast lawyer from DC is
actually a gang rapist
he's probably part of ms-13 or something
right remember that believe we have to
believe all women and then after that
story passes no evidence by the way that
Cavanaugh ever even met his accuser she
changed her story multiple times no
evidence she couldn't tell us when the
party was at which the incident took
allegedly took place couldn't tell us
how many people were there who was there
what date it was nothing nothing the one
friend who she said yeah she'll
corroborate it the friend said no this
never happened I don't what are you
talking about nothing there and they
were ready to prosecute Brett Kavanaugh
a rape now we got Joe Biden a former
staffer who says that has a very
specific complaint against him
we've got some evidence from at the time
because her mother coincidentally called
in to a Larry King show to talk about
this she's got corroborating evidence at
the time because she told a friend when
it happened what happened none of that
is being covered and Hillary Clinton who
said we have to believe all women she
endorses him Stacey Abrams who said we
need to believe all women she endorses
him the founder of the me2 movement just
came out and endorsed Joe more or less
endorse Joe with a bunch of
mealy-mouthed words listen to this is
unbelievable so she's widely credited as
being one of the founders of the
movement - Rana Burke
she said my stance has never wavered
survivors have a right to speak their
truth and to be given a place to heal
okay so now wait hold on I thought the
me2 movement was believed women who say
that men raped them because they're they
haven't been believed before now the
stance is people who who experience
sexual assault have a right to speak
they've always had a right to speak they
have a First Amendment that's not can't
be what the me2 movement is but they're
moving the goal posts the inconvenient
truth is that this story is impacting us
differently because it hits at the heart
of one of the most important elections
in our lifetime here we go every
election right every single elections
the most important election in our
lifetime especially the left and I hate
to disappoint you but I don't really
have easy answers yeah you don't because
if you followed the logic of your own
position you would have to obviously
withdraw any endorsement from Joe Biden
and then here it is I love this this is
the the logic on the one hand Tara Reid
the accuser has been afforded the
opportunity to speak her truth through
mainstream media reporting on her claims
and ongoing investigative journalism she
should have been able to come forward in
a process when she was treated fairly in
a trusted system instead like other
public's survivors before her she had to
rely on journalists in order to be heard
precisely because the systems for
survivors are not in place so she's
saying she's a survivor implying that it
is it is an established fact that this
woman survived a sexual assault on the
other hand she writes the defense of Joe
Biden shouldn't rest on whether or not
he's a good guy or our only hope the
defense of Joe Biden meaning look he's
the only Democratic candidate so we have
to defend him okay instead he could
demonstrate what it looks like to be
both accountable and electable all right
that's it
have no meaning anymore politics has no
meaning anymore it he could demonstrate
what it looks like to be accountable and
electable accountable to what
accountable to his crime it's what she's
saying he's already established that the
crime actually happened because Tara
Reid's a survivor and she knows that she
has to believe all women so therefore
Joe Biden committed the crime which is
why he's got to be held accountable but
we can't just throw him overboard
because this is the most important
election in our lifetime so he's also
got to be electable so now the head of
the me2 movement is saying we need to
elect a rapist because because he's a
leftist and because words have no
meaning and because I want to says the
mewtwo movement it would be difficult
for her to be clearer in this point the
me2 movement has gone from we got to
stop these terrible men and we got to
believe all women - let's elect a rapist
by the way you think that's going to get
covered in the mainstream media I don't
think so
all news is fake some of it is true what
does that mean that what that means is
occasionally a true story or a true fact
we'll make it through the mainstream
media but that is a bug not a feature of
the system okay that they're either the
true story I'll get through because the
editors didn't think it through
or because all of a sudden the truth
will fit the narrative the reason all
news is fake is because it's not news it
does not exist to report the news it
does not care about the truth it does
not care about investigation and
pursuing evidence and telling you what
actually happened that is not the point
and that has basically never been the
point but certainly now that is not the
point of the mainstream media the point
of the mainstream media is to push a
leftist narrative it will ignore facts
that are inconvenient it will invent
facts whole fantasies that will serve
its purpose i I know that conservatives
like to complain about this I'm not
complaining about this I'm simply
stating it as a fact the mainstream
media does not
exist to tell you the news the the news
is not the news the news is a left-wing
narrative we don't need to whine and
complain about that we just need to know
it and discard what they're saying or at
least discount what they're saying
sometimes you can get pretty good
information because there are good
reporters there and when it suits their
narrative you can get the good
information but beyond that you need to
question every single that not even
question you need to have a basic stance
of disbelief for anything you are
reading in the mainstream media and then
if it happens to be true you can be
pleasantly surprised but you should
never ever ever take anything in the
mainstream media at face value even when
it's true because when it happens to be
true you know that it is only being
reported to you because that truth
happens to serve the leftist agenda
beyond all of this fake news on another
aspect of corruption in our government
we're getting massive government
overreach because of this coronavirus
you know about the governor's and the
mayors that we've been reporting on but
it's going on with some of the cops too
there's a video that just came out from
some cops in Wisconsin a costing a
mother showing up at her door and
harassing her because she let her kid
play with a neighbor kid down the street
hi so are you aware that we're in a
stay-at-home order right now no you
don't need to explain if you need me to
you can you can because your officer was
just here two weeks ago could you man he
explained it to me that you guys weren't
enforcing that order oh we're about to
okay you understand it okay so why are
you here cuz your daughter is going to
play at other people's home and you're
allowing it to happen they were over
here as well so are you here okay so I
understand okay and so either you can
acknowledge it or you can or I may I'm
acknowledging it okay stop having your
kid go by other people's home okay I
acknowledge it anything else no that was
it apparently there was some I
acknowledged it I acknowledged it
anything else
all right this
cop needs to get a new job you will
never find a bigger defender of cops
than me okay I got got friends who are
cops they have a very difficult job they
keep order they keep us safe but some
Punk's overstep their bounds and they
like to flex their power and this guy
would appear to be one of them
the way he's speaking is one do you know
what you're doing don't you do excuse me
excuse me do you know what you're doing
you're letting your daughter play with
her friend uh this is America you can't
let your daughter play with her friend
excuse me excuse me if you do you
understand what I'm telling you like
shut up dude give me a freakin break and
that by the way that's not it I love
that this woman recorded it I love to
this woman posted this on the Internet
I hope that I was wishing the whole time
I'm watching him like it's saying is
this a hoax is this really happening in
the United States of America but that
wasn't the end of it she goes yes I've
understood the absolutely idiotic things
you're telling me officer because
because by the way when we think of the
epicenter of the corona virus we think
of Wisconsin right we think of the
middle of nowhere you can see the woods
all over Wisconsin that's where it's
happening right not in the big cities
like New York or anything like that this
is by the way what are we in the fifth
or sixth week into this when we were
told initially two million four million
Americans are gonna die now that number
has been reduced by well over an order
of magnitude and yet as the virus seems
less virulent day by day the enforcement
mechanisms of the state get more and
more intense they double down on their
power grab that wasn't even the end of
it she says can I go now where we good
and this other woman says absolutely not
we're gonna put your name in a report
and we're gonna make sure that you never
let your daughter play with another kid
again
I'm not is there a reason you're asking
for it you to the screen so we can
documents that we had contact with you
is there a reason for it which is up if
you let me finish that's what I'm
explaining to you because you're
violating in order
I haven't violated in order we're gonna
have documentation in our screen with
your name because we're here talking to
you about that that you said you just
acknowledged okay I would like to see
the law that requires me to give you
that information
oh I love this woman I want this woman
to run for governor she's so good how
she's handling them because by the way
the cops they're they don't have an
answer for what the law what's the law I
never heard of that thing the law do you
spell that l a8 o L aw okay I got a look
that I'm gonna Google that when I get
home
initially the woman goes yeah I need
your name so vindictive yeah I need your
name and the woman says why do you need
my name and then the cop says III if you
let me finish I'm telling you no you
didn't you're not explaining anything
you're you just asked for her name and
the woman asked you a question why and
then you got even more aggressive and
then she finally here's the kicker she
says show me the law crimes I have to do
this show me the law earth I'm not
allowed to let's settle up my daughter
play with another kid and the cop
totally dumbfounded both of them what a
disgrace what a disgraceful interaction
we just saw it's going on all over the
country enough enough of this gavin
newsom daddy Newsom the Governor of
California you know he's he's been
lightening up a little bit on how to
open up California he says okay alright
now that obviously all of our models and
predictions were wrong and there's a lot
of evidence that the lockdown isn't
helping anybody at all and and and now
that we've listened to Huey Lewis and
the news we're gonna start slowly
opening up California so we're in open
up retail shops and schools and daycare
but we're not going to open up churches
for months fine whatever dude whatever
just open it up right
no now he's making good on a threat that
he made a few days ago he said listen if
you're not all good little boys and
girls I'm not going to let you go to the
beach this weekend
we said please daddy Newsom please let
us go to the beach we'll be good little
formerly free Americans and he said no
well he's making good on that a source
close to Fox LA it just reported that a
California will be closing all the
beaches even the ones that they'd
started to open this weekend because
governor Newsom is very upset that we
weren't all good little boys and girls
last weekend and some people showed up
to the beach and they didn't stay far
enough apart the more the evidence cuts
against this hysterical alarmist
narrative the more the power grabbers
are going to double down very sad
situation how has it happened in large
part it's happened because we have been
hypnotized by the fake news media
because we believe mistakenly that the
mainstream media are reporting the news
they're not they are a propaganda
apparatus for power-hungry idiots
whether they're in the federal
bureaucracy or whether they're in the
Statehouse in California or whether
there's some two-bit cops in Wisconsin
screaming at a woman and intimidating
her because she let her little daughter
play with her friend
enough of that it's over forget the
whole narrative okay especially now that
the scientific data are actually
contradicting these alarmists sometimes
in the pages of the New York Times
itself okay enough of that ice you know
tonight steven crowder
is going to be doing a special on
coronavirus and he it will be using his
a typical flair to be presenting the
evidence for for these lockdowns
and the evidence against it in the
evidence against giving away so many of
our political rights I sat down and
chatted with mr. Crowder just a few days
ago we'll get to that in a second first
though you've got to go to daily
wire.com slash subscribe you got to
become an insider plus our all-access
member when you do that right now
you get so left us tears tumblr that's
very important right yeah what if I told
you you get another left just yours
tumblr that's right not just one you get
to use that one would that be good
that'd be good enough but to that is I
think approximately double as good so
head on over to
the only word I come especially you know
if you're watching Crowder's stream
tonight you're gonna obviously be
smoking a stogie and hashing it into the
ladder with Crowder ashtray which even
very good high quality ashtray so you
don't want to drink something while
you're doing that do it with your left
is to your Stumbler right now you get an
additional 10% off with coupon code
Noel's daily wire comm coupon cold
coupon code you do coupon code Knowles
go to daily wired I come we'll be right
back with steven crowder and the mailbag
all right i sat down with steven crowder
before his big coronavirus stream
tonight here's what he had to say it's
the mob and I'm not saying that all
these people are Nazis okay I want to be
really clear but when people say how
could that ever happen how could a group
of people ever be so vilified that
people were willing to snitch on them
and turn them into the SS well I don't
know
how could someone call the authorities
to send men with guns after a mom for
swinging her child in the park
everything all over the country - so all
these these snitch lines you know de
Blasio has one which some of my
listeners sent some lovely photographs
to I think other people did as well you
had this in in Laredo Texas you had this
in California so you have all these
snitch lines now I remember when I saw
the headline about the contact racing it
said Apple and Google team up and I
didn't even finish the headline I saw
Apple and Google team up I said get the
Go Bag yes exactly
people were preparing for like some kind
of an EMT attack or something when you
watch Preppers no no no it was just Tim
Cook and Zuckerberg having a cocktail
hour and all of a sudden all of our
information is public and our rights are
gone do you realize people it's it's the
dark night right with Morgan Freeman
saying you couldn't go this far with
Christian Bale sorry Bruce Wayne I'm
getting my I'm getting names and
characters mixed up at the fictional and
the reality but these said listen this
is this is the nanny state we can't be
doing this we're at this point where
people are demanding it and so even if
this government doesn't acquiesce to it
the next government can once you have
that data who believes that who believes
that Apple and Facebook are going to
destroy it that's how they make money
that's how they track you down like mrs.
pac-man with advertisements for you
every time you log in you think they're
all of a sudden gonna just light it in a
house fire after this it is so
terrifying to me that people are not
only giving up civil rights with sort of
a give-and-take they're demanding that
they be taken away from them and it's
crazy to me to see some of these
conservatives out there who are still
demanding it well that's the trouble
they're still demanding I get it
I'm willing to admit the states have a
police power in times of war in times of
plague right that even the federal
government has that power so I get it
but now we have the data the whole point
of the lockdowns was don't overwhelm the
hospital system and try to drag this
thing out until we have a vaccine we're
not gonna get a vaccine within a year
and the hospital system is not
overwhelmed all those in Javits Center
all that is is empty so now there is no
argument for the lockdowns and yet now
you still have even conservatives saying
we need to prolong it were you surprised
at how fast the Conservatives rolled
over some no some yes yeah some no some
yes I mean you know I was pretty
flippant about it and that one point
remember behind the scenes going like oh
no is this gonna be worse and that's you
know I'm already in this now so I just
had to keep going with it you know I had
my doctor on I had my personal physician
on and we did some bits and it was kind
of funny but he talked about I mean
early early on I told people listen I
don't know why they're saying don't wear
masks I think it's because they need
them for health care workers but here's
how you can make a mask at home and by
the way I got that information from an
article that was highlighted by the CDC
years ago so they're telling you not to
wear masks if you were a masking at 70
percent effective in filtering as you
breathe in the air and it's almost a
hundred percent effective in making sure
that you're airborne droplets don't make
it out well I like those odds I don't
know why people are still trusting the
medical establishment like these
conservatives when if they've been doing
a flip-flop I mean they said don't wear
masks they said it couldn't be
transmitted from human to human contact
the World Health Organization listened
YouTube and Facebook they're saying
we're going to remove anything that
doesn't that isn't in line right that
isn't Congress with the World Health
Organization standards but hold a second
what if they're wrong like when they
said no human of human contact but first
off doesn't even require a scientist
doesn't even require a scientist to know
that if a virus exists you probably
shouldn't be grown in people's faces
like I've read it back then and going
okay even if this is severe and I didn't
think was going to be you shouldn't be
licking people's neck right of course
they just it's this bizarre thing where
even the conservatives now are trusting
governments that
are changing their mind within five
minutes it is actually like 1984 to me
the mask thing was the best one because
it was the Surgeon General tweets out he
goes stop buying masks multiple
exclamation points then the next day buy
masks yeah I was like Oceania has always
been at war with Eastasia it's like
totally Orwellian yeah and yet we're
still trusting it and amidst all of this
you've got the crazy coronavirus stuff
this is how whipped up into a frenzy we
are is that few days ago the US
government came out and admitted
acknowledged to my knowledge for the
first time ever that there are UFOs yeah
actual unidentified flying objects and
do you know what the reaction of most
people was yeah whatever let's keep
talking about how Orange I guess Tom
from blink 182 needed a win you know and
I you know what frankly I still think
he's an idiot he makes a very good point
he'll get into that much more probably
not the UFOs as much but he will get
into coronavirus much more tonight so go
check that one out let's get to the
mailbag from Robbie in your opinion who
is the greater threat to the United
States Russia or China China it's that's
very easy people who say Russia are the
same people who cheered on the rise of
China and said that China should go join
the World Trade Organization and who
turned a blind eye to China's stealing
our intellectual property and illegally
subsidizing its steel and aluminium and
playing games with its own currency and
people who who believed in a world order
that is not coming to fruition like they
promised us and which is breaking down
all around us I think of the the Russia
answer on that is kind of like that Mitt
Romney energy you know it's just it's so
unimaginative it's caught up in this
world view that just day by day seems
less and less connected with reality
whereas the real threat which has been
right in front of our nose for 20 years
is China from Anthony hey Michael I'm a
recent high school grad from
Philadelphia and a recent daily wire
subscriber lately I've been thinking
back on some of my history classes in
school and how many of them took such a
far left-wing approach to most of the
lessons that
into too much detail some of these
lessons were misleading or just flat-out
lies as to how things really were and
the effect they had on our country so it
got me thinking about how my future
generations be taught about the Trump
presidency in school especially when
compared to past presidents will they be
taught the truth will it be something
similar to have a media portrays
President Trump or a mixture of both no
it will be a left-wing perspective that
is what happens in schools that is the
purpose of schools that is why you know
used to be you went to school from first
grade to twelfth grade and then very
small number of people went to college
and that was it and then you got out
into the world and then they added
kindergarten and then they added
basically you you've got to go to
college right they've said that college
is a human right and everyone's got to
go to college even if you take out a lot
of loans to do it and even if you don't
get a decent education for it and even
if you're never going to be able to pay
back those loans because you don't get a
good job so they extend College out that
way now you basically have to go to
pre-k I never went to pre-k but that
seems like now I know people whose kids
are like 2 years old and they go to
pre-k now pre pre pre K so they just
keep extending that out because it gives
the state and it gives the left-wing
culture more of an opportunity to teach
their own highly dubious view of the
world so that is pretty much always
going to be the case certainly as long
as the left controls the culture which
isn't going to change anytime soon I do
think though there is an advantage here
for some conservatives which is when
you're taught all of this stuff in
school for 12 years or 13 years or 20
years or however long you're in school
you know the left-wing argument very
well and so when you know the
conservative argument is well you're in
a much better position to make your
points and I mean even forget about
interpersonal debate even just to
understand what you think because you've
got all the best arguments from the left
and then you can on your own accumulate
the arguments from the right and you can
weigh them and see which ones are better
the left does not have that opportunity
the left knows what they know all right
they know the left-wing point of view
most of them have never encountered the
right-wing point of view they have no
idea what we believe they think that
you're pro-life because you hate women
they think that you define marriage in
the way that everyone has always defined
marriage
more or less because you hate
homosexuals they they they just don't
get it right they think that you voted
for Trump because you're you you might
seem like a polite person on the outside
but secretly you're this bigoted monster
whatever they just don't understand and
so it gives you a real real competitive
advantage in all of that in terms of
discovering the truth for yourself and
arguing your points from flu what a
great name dear Michael you said you
believed work is intrinsic to human
nature I am inclined to agree with you
and the biblical account of this is
found in Genesis that you put forth
however the ancient Greeks proposed that
man's purpose was leisure their word for
leisure was Skol am i pronouncing that
correctly hope so which gives us words
like school and scholar they believed
that by learning they would fulfill
their concept of leisure and ultimately
reach perfect happiness eudaimonia what
are your thoughts on this pox at bonum
yeah there's there's quite a lot to be
gained from this I mean I don't think
that those two things are incompatible
I'm not saying that the entire purpose
or even the primary purpose of life is
for us to grind ourselves into the dust
and make a bunch of widgets I don't
think that at all I think we are made to
work part of what we are here to do is
to work that is a part of our human
nature but of course there are higher
things as well one thing to be careful
of here though is that the Greek the
ancient Greek conception of leisure is
not the way that we think of leisure
today when we think of leisure we think
of just kind of edging out on the couch
and watching Tiger King that is
certainly not what Aristotle was
thinking of that idea of leisure is not
it's not like downtime that idea of
leisure is using your mind for the
higher pursuits that are good in and of
themselves and of course that's true I
mean I I think and I break with a lot of
people on the right these days when I
say this but that this is why liberal
arts education is so important to not
just conservatives but to anybody who
wants to be a free person because the
liberal arts are the arts that allow us
to make sense of our freedom and to earn
our freedom and you know the idea is
contrary to the liberal narrative what
happens in reality is you are not born a
free individual in a state of nature -
and you know then society shackles you
it's actually the
you're born a slave you are born a slave
to your passions a slave to your
appetites and desires and you have to
steadily discipline yourself to earn and
make sense of your freedom so that when
you're older you can be a free man and
certainly the leisure the skull the
scholars you have all those stuff that
the ancient Greeks are talking about
that is the way to do that so I think
those two go hand in hand and and also
the idea of making sense of our freedom
it's not that it's just some
disconnected abstract idea that we can
think about merely from our ivory towers
but it's something that we actually have
to put into practice and habits every
day in the way that we live our lives
here with this body on this earth day by
day from Christina my husband is still
working and we really don't need our
stimulus check should I return it to the
government or give it to folks who
really need it
yeah you should give it to folks who
really need it you should certainly not
give it to the government they will
squander it they won't notice that it
won't it won't do any good
they will waste it you will use your
money better than the federal government
when it comes to your stimulus check I
promise you so you want to give it to
charity or maybe even better just give
it to a friend or somebody you know of a
friend of a friend who who could use it
that'd be great use of your check from
Patrick dear mister future successor to
Kim jong-un had listened to every
episode of yours since day one and
finally jumped aboard the USS Daily wire
shoutout promo code Knoll so thank you
very much that's very kind my question
is why is there such a divide in opinion
between the Twitter world and the real
world over the past year you would have
thought bado
Kamala and Warren we're all Xuan's for
the nomination at various times if you
only looked at Twitter however their
support in public polling was never
really significant at all came from been
paid for Michael yeah this is something
that even many conservatives forget and
certainly people who are on Twitter all
the time
Twitter is not the real world okay
my grandmother barely knows what Twitter
is she does she actually does know cuz
because of Trump but my grandma doesn't
log on to Twitter and tweet all day most
people are not on Twitter the the reason
that Twitter matters is because all the
jurors are on Twitter so all of the
people who write the whole main
through media and the whole popular
culture in Hollywood they're all on
Twitter so it has this outsized
influence or it it appears to have this
outsized influence I think of it like
The Daily Show with Jon Stewart when Jon
Stewart came on the air with The Daily
Show you know now decades ago it was
considered the most important biggest
show in the country everyone talked
about the influence Jon Stewart was
having but very few people actually
watched the show the thing is all of the
journalists who are writing the news
stories watched the quote-unquote news
stories watched the show and so that
became the narrative that's what's going
on with Twitter but yeah if you're
basing your vision of the world on
Twitter that is not going to be a good
vision because the people who are on it
disproportionately are living in a world
of ideology that has been abstracted
from and is separate from reality and so
very often they're the least reliable
people to tell you what's really going
on from Austin dear mr. Knowles I'm part
of a of the came for Ben's stay for
Noel's crew I'm in a serious
relationship and we were planning on
getting married I had a conversation
with Rebecca solecism and she was
somewhat antagonistic toward the idea of
following the institution she is a
Christian but had had bad experience
with Catholicism specifically as a child
herself she argued we be Christians
meaning Protestant and raise a family
following Christ but outside the
Catholic Church I did not have a good
response as I'm still coming back into
the faith I am wanting to become closer
to my faith as a Catholic but I'm not
sure if this is something I should be
overly concerned about with regards to
her we aligned on all the other issues
any advice you could offer to be
appreciated thank you yes
this is a tough answer but you asked a
tough question you cannot do that you
cannot be a Catholic and then not be a
Catholic you know you view it this is
sometimes hard for Protestants to
understand because the idea of
Protestantism is it's you know it's a
little bit looser when it comes to these
institutional rigid requirements the
ideas you could start in one
denomination move to another
denomination shop for a church go to a
different church you can't do that with
Catholicism the the the big
differentiating factor here is the
sacraments right the Catholic Church
claims apostolic succession traces it
back to Peter administers the sacraments
which it believes are really and truly
the coming together of heaven and earth
most precisely in the Eucharist right
which is a different understanding of
what the Eucharist is then what broadest
Protestants believe broadly speaking
that it is a symbol of Christ and
Catholics believe it is literally the
body and blood of Christ and so you
cannot absent yourself from that you
cannot xx communicate yourself from the
that sacrament also just as a practical
matter if you try to get Mary it is not
permitted for Catholics to not be
married in the Catholic Church and if
you do try to get married in the
Catholic Church to a Protestant which is
totally possible it's very easy to to
get a bishop to sign off on that you
have to promise to raise the kids
Catholic and you probably don't want to
start off your marriage with a lie if
that's not gonna be what you do so I
don't I don't think you should be harsh
about this or mean about this or say but
you do need to explain it to your fiance
because a lot of people just don't know
about it a lot of Catholics don't even
know about it so that's important one
bit here though that might help you is
regardless of the the Protestant
denomination that your fiance is a
member of it tends to be among
conservatives here that Protestant
Catholic everyone alike will say that
the man should have a sort of leadership
role in the household certainly
spiritually and so that might be one way
to say listen if we were really going to
be conservative and traditional and
biblical here then maybe we should go
with my version of Christianity rather
than your version might get you slapped
in the face if you make that argument
too but it is that's the Genesis 3
argument for for this sort of thing
really what you should do is obviously
talk this out faith is a very important
thing it doesn't sound like you're
totally far apart here but that is a
sticking point and I think even if you
don't come to an agreement on it which
would be a sad conclusion even if you
don't you should at least explain what
that sticking point is and why it
matters from Joshua do you think another
round of payments directly to Americans
are warranted at this point speaking of
someone who had a salary reduction and
would receive a check I still think it's
a mistake in the long run with our debt
yeah it is a mistake we shouldn't get
people accustomed to universal basic
income that was a little band-aid during
the peace
of this insane unprecedented event but
that's not a solution it's not a
solution for just the government to
print more money and give it to people
and pretend that that's going to solve
these problems it is not we need to
reopen the country from John last
question mr. Knowles is there a
defensible reason to explain the
disparity of news coverage between the
accusers of Kavanagh and Biden assuming
there is none how can this be used to
expose the charade of the left to the
whole world if we don't have mainstream
media on the side of truth Thanks
wow that was a providential final
question because the reason is that all
news is fake news some of it is true but
all of it is fake so when it serves the
left's interest to say something true
they will and we and conservatives get
really excited about that but it doesn't
change the underlying fact of what the
news media the mainstream news media or
in the United States which is fake news
and there's something to help us get
back to the side of truth yeah be aware
of that fact and you know check your
sources and read other stuff all right
that's our show and watch this show by
the way
okay have a good weekend I will be doing
an all-access show later tonight so if
you are an all-access member I think
right now we're still doing it for all
of the members though we're only going
to do that one or two more times so if
you're there I will see you tonight in
the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
fenders hair and makeup
Nika Geneva production assistant Ryan
love the Michael Knowles show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]